thank you
[Music]
so you guys heard about the Trump grape
allegations where what oh right didn't
you do the do the deposition yeah so he
is um wow being deposed for a a incident
that a woman claimed happened in New
York in like the 90s and she says that
they were they were in like a department
store and Trump like like
um forced her to have sex with him whoa
like in a like a dress Robinson May
Robinson's mayor like a Bloomingdale's
yeah oh that's old school robust is
amazing old school I think that makes a
difference like if it's a Bloomingdale's
or if it's a Robinson
imagine Trump trump taking you shopping
and it's Robinson's mate yeah better
than the mervins he's like staying this
this rack over here all right all right
it's a Macy's Macy's go pick out any
Union Bay you like
it would have been a good one yeah he
[__] propped her up on the [__]
Sears washing machine and he's like
right here while Everyone's Watching
yeah How likely is it that it is true so
100 the lady the lady was on CNN and
gave a very interesting interview with
Anderson Cooper who we all know and love
we love it yeah it's my favorite CIA
asset yep probably far
um no he um he he she gave an interview
with him where she said that the idea of
rape is hot and then he had to cut the
commercial it was kind of want so that's
the same woman that's what she said she
did that's the same woman who is
deposing Trump and when they were asking
Trump about what happened this is what
he said
dude Trump is just busy in court all the
time now a little bit when you said in
that video that misleads would not be
your first choice
you were referring to her physical looks
correct.com
I look at her I see her I hear what she
says whatever you wouldn't be a choice
of mine either to be honest
I would not under any circumstances have
any interest in you
I'm big I'm honest to what I say it she
I would not have any interest in
bro he's like he's not he's I love not
trying to be funny
how he he makes it so like he breaks
that professional wall and he brings
people that are physically there into
everything that he's doing everything
and also he's got to get his own
material because this dude is just doing
all the best Impressionists of trump
like he's just he just can't stop like
he's his hand it's almost like he's in
on it like he's doing it more now than
ever he's a killer yeah holy [__] he's
like you know I think you're also an
ugly you're disgusting he's like imagine
I can't even I would never [__] you
either
wasn't even in the question he wasn't
even asking yeah yeah yeah
like oh my God the Savage Apple you
you're not a looker you wouldn't be my
first choice either you don't feel bad
he's like you probably wouldn't be my
50th Choice sister he's basically
socking the ref he's he's unfaced like
he's I think for someone that's in his
position to be in all the court cases
that he's in I think they'd be a little
stressed out you don't look stressed out
no he doesn't look worried I just
watched this other one where this
reporter tried to call him out about
covet right and he goes you know South
Korea they're doing like 11 tests how
come we're not doing the same amount and
he goes I think you're wrong he goes
yeah America's doing five tests a day or
whatever and he goes no no so I think
you're completely wrong and then he goes
yes he goes okay where's your numbers
where's your numbers and then he goes
and he gets his uh secretary and she
goes so South Korea is at 11 tests and
the US is at 17 and he goes see there
you go uh are you gonna apologize now
are you gonna apologize and he's all
like that's why you're from Yahoo news
and no one no one knows who you are yeah
oh he has to [__] do the last that's
why no one listens to your Yahoo news
app extra foot of ground above the
coffee but in a lot of people's eyes
right he won that exchange and and like
he just smashed on this random person so
everyone's like well that's great
because he wins exchanges because people
can't they can't dip to that level to
respond in the same way they're not
Roasters it just sounds like New York
business like old school 80s like that's
how they talk behind yeah and they're
[__] bringing it to them for each
other and yeah it's entertaining us
here's this chick Eugene Carroll
so I just Lawrence I wish I had said I
wish I said I'll tell you my age if you
show me your tax returns yeah it would
have been would have been helpful
so that's just one one little snippet of
an interview here's a there's a there's
a couple that I'm going to show you
right now I'll tell you my age
and that's why I don't use the word you
just use I use the word fight
you don't use the word rape
sexual violence is in every country in
every strata of society and I just feel
that so many women are undergoing sexual
bonds and mine was short I got out I'm
happy now I'm moving on
um and I think of all those who are
enduring
constant sexual violence so this one
incident this one what three minutes in
this little dressing room
I just say it's a fight that way I'm not
the victim okay
huh a what I'm having trouble
understanding wait wait so did moments
of awkward moments that she's had to do
they have did they actually have sex
what was the ACT what was the context
around everything so she says that they
were at a department store she got
pulled into it okay so they were at
Robinson May and then she was like you
think I'm a chirp image
Goodman but yeah whatever yeah I never
heard of the story about it yet oh okay
okay
but this is the one that I thought was
kind of wild but these are all kind of
like these are all kind of weird moments
that she's had in interviews that that
are are kind of interesting
which the word wraith carries so many
sexual connotation this was nuts this
was not sexual for it just it hurt it
just what it just you know I think most
people think of rape and as I mean it is
a violence so she's defended I think
most people say the rapist being sexy
that sounds like something you would say
I know so yeah it's sexy she really said
that she's probably reading too many
Daniel Steel novels and Cooper really
said oh let's take a break and she she
kind of kept going here for a sec but
yeah we've got to take a quick break
dude he's like stammering you're
fascinating to talk to she's she's
Bonkers bro she's A demented old grandma
you're fascinating
fight him
right [__] bro I don't know what to
think of that yeah what is she even
saying it's like can you believe I
wasn't bullshitting about that yeah
is that not Biden yeah I'm like they all
sound like demented old people
like so she's already saying it's an it
was a non-sexual altercation I don't
know why she keeps saying it over and
over and over again but it's sexual
violence but it's non-sexual and she's
talking about a bunch of women in other
countries and she doesn't like to use
the word rape because it turns her on
too hard is she she's not in politics
but then it's sexy she's just some lady
I don't know she's he's just some lady
some lady yeah she used to work at
Macy's and then Trump dragged her to the
Robinson maybe but Trump trump admits
that he did hang hang with her and they
did go to stuff no he says he doesn't
remember her at all and he thinks he
would have remembered her but he thinks
she's also like a two he's like she's
very forgettable she has a very
forgettable face you probably I mean
that is a good argument he goes look I
bang models like why would we why would
I get a Robinson's Mayweather she looks
like she could have been bad
what is going on the news doesn't say
the news doesn't say anything the
evolution think about it 30 years ago
she was probably bad yeah I mean you
think so let's let's do it because she
don't look ugly there she just said for
30 years ago photo
we'll see about that Anthony again you
know what I'm saying though she's just
saying weird [__] so it's weird but if
you really just look at her 30 years ago
she probably she's a little odd you know
what I mean she she seems a little off
her rocker yeah but she also apparently
went through a fight in a I just don't
know what the purpose of her explaining
that so hard it is I mean but maybe I
don't know that's tough is this a bad
that was hurt Bob yeah the turn I guess
back then
what do you think Colleen it probably
was longer than that before that she's
not alone
watch me there's one there's one even
older than that here she's not ugly
right what do you think
what do you think clean like objectively
what do you think
a lot of makeup hard to tell I want to
make it five out of ten she's very
presentable I'll give you that I don't
know she looks like somebody who
encounters a lot of uh sexual violence
yeah
she doesn't take me as she doesn't take
me as someone who likes uh rape
fantasies
it's kind of interesting
it's very confusing
I think she's confused
I don't know we're going to commercial
approach
we're going to commercial break what's
going on you're an interesting person to
talk to yeah this is her these are 30
years ago does she not know she's on TV
she's holy [__] Topanga
that's the Banger bro
if you pulled out Minkus bro
she she kind of looks like Minkus I was
more of a Kelly capacity guy you should
have pulled up Ferris Bueller yeah bro
that's that's a join the club that's a
Holy Grail so what's going on is is
Trump going to jail probably not
I don't I don't think so do you
have no idea that interview was
hilarious though